اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض التي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات السعوديه والخليج
وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
اوكرانيا تقول ان جيشها حقق استقرارا حول
باخمه وبريطانيا تكشف توقف الهجوم الروسي
على المدينه
مفوض سياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
يصف خطه بكين لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه بغير
الكافيه
مطار الملك عبد العزيز بجده يسجل اصول نحو
ربع مليون معتمر لاداء العمره خلال شهر
رمضان
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه كذلك
خلال اقل من عامين على تاسيسها المنتخب
السعودي للسيدات يدخل تصنيف الاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم
انقاص الوزن او الحفاظ عليه تحدي سنوي
يواجه غالب الاشخاص الصائمين خلال شهر
رمضان
حياكم الله نبدا من التطورات الميدانيه في
اوكرانيا حيث اكد رئيس الاركان الاوكراني
ان قوات بلاده تمكنت من تحقيق الاستقرار
في مدينه باكموت التي تشهد اعنف المعارك
منذ اندلاع الحرب وقال على حسابه في
فيسبوك ان تحقيق الاستقرار جاء بفضل جهود
الرائعه لقوات الدفاع الاوكرانيه
هذا وكان بيان لوزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
قد افاد بان الهجوم الروسي على بلده باقم
الشرقي اوكرانيا توقف بشكل كبير نتيجه
الاستنزاف الشديد لقوات موسكو اوضحان
البيان ان الجانب الاوكراني تكبى خلال تلك
المعارك الدفاعيه تكبد خسائر فادحه وبحسب
الدفاع البريطانيه قد يكون الوضع الروسي
سيئا بسبب التوتر بين وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ومجموعه فاجنر العسكريه اشار
البيان الى انه من المحتمل ان تحول روسيا
تركيزها العمليه نحو
ايضا كذلك نحو اسباتوف وكريمينيا لاستعاده
الاستقرار في خطها الامامي
من كيف يلتحق بنا الصحفي محمد الباب السيد
محمد مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض اباك مت كانت قاب قوسين
او ادنى من ان تسقط في يد قوات فاجنر قوات
الروسيه شبه الرسميه لكن البيان بيان
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه يؤكد عكس هذا
الكلام تماما القوات الروسيه انسحبت او
تقهقرت من هذه المنطقه ويبدو ان الامور
يعني تعود زمامها شيئا فشيئا الى الجيش
الاوكراني وهذا ايضا حسب تصريح احد
الجنرالات ما الذي تغير في معادله
نعم بالفعل نايف وربما على مدى اسبوعين او
ثلاثه اسابيع كنا نتكلم عن استراتيجيه
الجيش الاوكراني في الدفاع عن مدينه يعني
خلال الفتره الماضيه الجيش الاوكراني يعني
استخدم سياسه او استراتيجيه استنزاف القوه
الضاربه لمجموعه فارنير الروسي التي كانت
تهاجم باعداد كبيره ولكن كانت تتلقى خسائر
بالمئات فمثلا يعني قبل حوالي ثلاثه
اسابيع كانت ان مليار نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني كانت تقول ان الجيش الاوكراني
يقتل جميع المهاجمين الروس ثم تاتي
مجموعات اخرى تدوس على جثث الجنود الروسي
القتلى وتحاول التقدم ثم يقوم الجيش
الاوكراني باستهداف هذه المجموعات الجديده
يعني المتجدده ثم هذا السيناريو يتكرر
بشكل يومي وعلى مدار الساعه وعلى مدى
حوالي ثلاثه اشهر استنزفت القوات الروسيه
وخسرت اعداد كبيره جدا وبحسب يعني الضباط
او مصادر لنا في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
اكثر من 25 30 الف مقاتل من قتلوا فقط منذ
يعني بدايه شهر جانيوري او بدايه راس
السنه حتى هذه اللحظه اي على مدى ثلاثه
اشهر ما يعني عند استراتيجيه الجيش
الاوكراني كانت استنزاف القوات الروسيه
بالعتاد وبالجنود ولذلك منذ حوالي يومين
او ثلاثه ايام تغيرت طبيعه المعارك اصبح
الجيش الاوكراني لديه اليد الطول باستهداف
القوات الروسيه خفت وتيره الهجوم الروسي
بشكل كبير كانت القدرات الروسيه
تحاول التقدم غربا لحصار مدينه بالكامل
الا ان هذه الخطه وبدات القوات الروسيه
وبحسب معلومات من الجيش الاوكراني وهذه
معلومات يعني قبل دقائق حصلنا عليها بدات
القوات الروسيه تنسحب تدريجيا الى الحدود
الشرقيه لمدينه ممتاز هنا نسال هل السبب
في يعني
ما حدث هناك وخساره هذه المنطقه على الاقل
يعني حسب هذه التصريحات لوزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه وكذلك ايضا للاوكرانيا هل هي
بسبب الصدام الذي حدث والذي يعني تتحدث
عنه وسائل الاعلام ايضا بين الجيش الروسي
وقوات باجنرشيب الرسميه ام لان الجيش
الروسي غير من شكل عملياته ركزها نحو يعني
وكذلك
فبالتالي هذا الانسحاب الذي تتحدث عنه من
باقمت هو لغرض التوجه وربما لتركيزها
العمليات على هذه المناطق
هناك ثلاثه اسباب الرئيسيه ادت الى يعني
ممكن القول تراجع او فشل خطه الجيش الروسي
باحتلال مدينه اولا طبيعه مدينه والدفاعات
الاوكرانيه والاستراتيجيه الاوكرانيه التي
تتبعها عبر استنزاف القوات الروسيه ضرب
مخازن الاسلحه ثانيا اصطدام الكبير
والخلاف الكبير بين مجموعه فاغني كمجموعه
عسكريه قتاليه ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه وكنا
نرسم على مدى شهر او شهر ونصف خلافات
كثيره وانتقادات من رئيس مجموعه
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه بعدم تسليم الاسلحه
والعتاد وحتى عدم السماح له بتجنيد
مقاتلين جدد بعد نفاذ معظم القوه الضاربه
لمجموعه وبحسب المعلومات يعني
حوالي 80 الى 90% من مجموعات فارتنر
الهجوميه القتاليه ثالثا استراتيجيه الجيش
الاوكراني واستراتيجيه الجيش الروسي الجيش
الاوكراني في ظل العمليات العسكريه
والهجوم الضاغط على
يحرك قوته في شرق او في المنطقه الشرقيه
لباخمت بالقرب من ليمان بالقرب من
وكريمينيا وبذلك كان يحاول الجيش
الاوكراني قطع خطوط الامداد العسكريه
للجيش الروسي في تلك المنطقه الان اتجهت
يعني العمليات الى تلك المنطقه شمالا
باتجاه كريمينيا وجنوبا باتجاه وذلك
استطاع الجيش الاوكراني تخفيف الضغط
الكبير عن مدينه توسيع الجبهه وايضا لا
ننسى ان الجيش الاوكراني يحاول كسر الوقت
للحصول على العتاد والذخائر التي يحتاجها
للقيود للقيام بالهجوم المضاده وما نراه
يعني ونتائج هذه يعني يمكن نتيجه
استراتيجيه الجيش الاوكراني الناجحه كما
تعتبر حتى هذه اللحظه هو كسب الوقت وربما
سيكون الجيش الاوكراني خلال فتره اسبوعين
او ثلاثه اسابيع او حتى شهر عندما يستلم
العتاد والسلاح سيكون بالهجوم المضاد
بعدما انهيك القوات الروسيه بشكل كبير
وتشتت المجموعات الروسيه بين ثلاثه محاور
في الوسط ضخمه في الشمال الاكرميني وفي
الجنوب اجد وبذلك يمكن قول عنصر المفاجاه
الاوكراني اصبح واقعا وربما ستسقط
الدفاعات الروسيه ويتقدم الجيش الاوكراني
لتحرير الاراضي هذه الاستراتيجيه التي
يعني اصبحت واضحه للجميع استراتيجيات
الجيش
الصحفي محمد الباب على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل
قالت صحيفه ديلي تيليجرافينا الاتحاد
الاوروبي يدرس فرض قيود تجاريه ضد دول
اسيا الوسطى بدعوى انها تساعد روسيا في
تجاوز العقوبات الغربيه الصحيفه اوردت
بنود وثيقه داخليه للاتحاد الاوروبي جاء
فيها انه يجب ارسال رساله واضحه الى
الافراد والكيانات القانونيه في تلك الدول
بان توفير الدعم المادي للقوات الروسيه
والمجمع الصناعي العسكري ستكون له عواقب
وخيمه وستؤثر على وصولهم الى سوق الاتحاد
الاوروبي
اعتبر مفوض السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريلا ان خطه السلام
الصينيه لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه غير كافيه
لانهاء الصراع وقال بوريل انه بالرغم من
ان خطه السلام الصينيه غير كافيه لانهاء
الصراع في اوكرانيا الا انه لا يمكن
اعتبارها مواليه لروسيا واضاف ان زياره
الرئيس الصيني
قللت من خطر اندلاع حرب نوويه
هذا واعلن الرئيس فلودي ميرسي انه اشار
عبر قنوات الدبلوماسيه الى رغبته في
التحدث الى الرئيس الصيني
وقال انه لم يتلقى الدم بعد اضاف زيليسكي
ان عرض الوساطه الصينيه لم يصله مشيرا الى
ان هذا العرض يجب ان يحترم وحده وسياده
اراضي اوكرانيا اولا
من بروكسل ينضم الينا ناصر زهير المحلل
السياسي سيد ناصر مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه من الرياض كل عام وانت
بخير هذا التصريح لجوزير بان خطه السلام
الصينيه لحل الازمه غير كافيه وبعد ذلك
قال لا يمكن اعتبار الصين مواليه لروسيا
هل هذا يعبر عن انقسام بين دول النيتو
انقسام فيما يخص هذه الوساطه والخطه
الصينيه للسلام في اوكرانيا
تحياتي لكم وللمشاهدين وكل عام وانتم بخير
يعني في الاطار الاساسي يمكن اعتبار بان
تصريحات تعكس المواقف المتضاربه نوعا ما
اتجاه المبادره الصينيه في الخصوص في هذا
الايطالي ان الولايات المتحده رفضت هذه
المبادره بشكل كامل او بشكل قاطع الدول
الاوروبيه بحسب نقاشات التي كانت بالامس
وهو الامس في القمه الموجوده هنا في
البروكسل قالت او حاولت ان تعطي تصور بانه
يمكن جذب الصين لتكون طرف فعليا او ضاغط
للسلام بمعنى ان يكون لدينا جبهه اوروبيه
صينيه تسعى الى احلال السلام في اوكرانيا
ووقف القتال هذه النقطه بالتحديد هي ما
سيعمل عليها الرئيس ماكرون في زيارتها
القادمه بعد ايام الى الصين بالاضافه الى
ذلك ايضا رئيس الوزراء الاسباني وارسل
سيزورون ايضا الصين من اجل ان يكون هناك
دفع لضغط نوعا ما على روسيا وحتى ايضا فرض
معادله معينه على اوكرانيا من اجل الذهاب
الى طاوله
قادرون على على خطوه من من هكذا نوع مع
الصين بان يدفعوا الصين لكي تضغط على
حليفهم الروسي
نعم هذه هي الاطر الاساسيه عن الاوروبيين
يعولون على ان الصين لم تكن دعني اقول
دائما بشكل كبير في اوكرانيا في بدايتها
وانها فعليا تسعى الى انهاء هذه الحرب
ولكن ما هي الطريقه وما هو الشكل لان
البنود 12 التي طرحتها الصيني لحد هذه
اللحظه وجهه نظر الاوروبيين وحتى الولايات
المتحده لا تتضمن مسارات واضحه لانهاء هذه
الحرب ما هو
القرار بالنسبه لقاليم الاربعه التي ضمتها
روسيا وهذه نقطه خلاف كبيره بين الجانبين
ذات الوقت سيد ناصر هي هي اكدت على على
وحده الاراضي
الاوكرانيه هذا احد بنود هذه الخطه
والمبادره الصينيه فبالتالي الا يمكن ان
تكون هذه بادره صينيه قد تقبل من على
الاقل اطراف النيتو بالاضافه الى اوكرانيا
هذا صحيح
في اطار ان وقف القتال ماذا سي يعني بمعنى
هل سيتوقف القتال الان وتبقى الاراضي
الاقاليم الاربعه التي ستظهر عليها روسيا
مع روسيا ثم نذهب الى طاوله المفاوضات ام
هو الشرط الامريكي او الغربي بان الذهاب
الى المفاوضات يعني العوده الى الوضع قبل
بدايه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه هذه ايضا
نقطه خلاف بين الجانبين ولكن انا اعتقد
بان زياره ماكرون الى الصين مع المحادثات
الاوروبيه الصينيه يمكن ان تدفع نحو تشكيل
هذه الجبهه خاصه ان الصين تريد ايضا ان
يكون الاوروبيين معها في هذه المبادره
لانه بعد زياره الرئيس الصيني الى روسيا
اتصل كبير دبلوماسيين الصينيين بمستشار
الرئيس الفرنسي
ودفعه او حاول ان يشرح له الخطه وان يبعد
ان يدعوا الاوروبيين ليكونوا في هذه الخطه
للسلام يعني بمعنى اننا لازلنا في البدايه
اعتقد ان زياده ماكرون ستكون فاصله في
تحديد موقف الاوروبي من هذه المبادره
ودخولهم مع الصين في الوساطه هذا بالنسبه
للاوروبيين في هذه الوساطه لكن بالنسبه
لاحد اطراف هذه الازمه وهو الطرف
الاوكراني لم تتواصل معه بكين حتى هذه
اللحظه
يتحدث بانه طلب على الاقل موعدا لاجراء
ربما مقابله او اتصال مع الرئيس الصيني
ولا اجابه حتى هذه اللحظه لماذا احجمت
بكين عن التواصل مع
اوكرانيا وهي الطرف الاساسي في هذه الازمه
يعني الاجابه الدبلوماسيه تقول بان الصين
لا زالت
تعمل بل
ورد اساسي الاجابه الواقعيه هي ان تدرك
بانسكي واوكرانيا لا يملكون القرار في
قبول المبادره الصينيه ام لا بالتالي
الحديث يجب ان يكون مع الاطراف الغربيه
هذه الاطراف الغربيه العلاقه مع الصين
والولايات المتحده ليست جيده الان بمعنى
لا يمكن ان نتحدث الصينيين مع الامريكيين
هم يمكن ان يتحدثوا مع الاوروبيين اذا حدث
توافق اوروبي صيني حول صيغه المبادره
الصينيه وكيف ستكون وما هي البنود التي
ستسير عليها عندها ستكون هناك تواصل او
سيكون هناك تواصل بين الصين واوكرانيا
ودعوه او لقاء للرئيس الصيني مع المسؤولين
او رئيس الاوكراني مع المسؤولين الصينيين
من اجل ان تشرح المبادره وان يكون لديهم
ضغط للذهاب اليها ولكن الان الصين تريد ان
تحصل على موقعي الغرب او الموافقه الغربيه
المتمثله في الاوروبيه
في اي حاله برايك سيد ناصر يمكن في اي
حاله يمكن للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
تقبل بالوساطه الصينيه باختصار اذا سمحت
فقط الاوروبيين ودعمهم بهذه المبادره بشكل
كامل عندها يمكن ان تلين الولايات المتحده
وان يتحقق جزء من الشروط الاوكرانيه حتى
نقول بانها ساندت حليفها وحصلت على جزء من
الشروط التي يطلبه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
بروكسل زهير المحلل السياسي
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري ميدفي
كان قد اكد على ضروره زياده اعداد
المقاتلين في الجيش الى مليون ونصف على
الاقل من قال في تصريحات صحفيه بان روسيا
بحاجه الى الاعتماد على جيش مختلط من
المجندين والمتعقدين
اقترح رئيس مجلس الدوم الروسيه في ارسال
حضره اجراءات المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في
البلاد بعد ان اصدرت المحكمه مذكره اعتقال
بحق الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين متهمه
اياه بارتكاب جرائم حرب وقال فولودين
حليفه بوتين انه يتعين تعديل الدستور
الروسي لحظر اي نشاط للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه في الدوله ومعاقبه اي شخص يقدم
المساعده والدعم للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
هذا وتتصاعد وتيره التهديد الروسي للغرب
فموسكو تحذر من استمرار تزويد اوكرانيا
بالسلاح كما ان المسؤولين الروس لم
يترددوا في الاشاره للسلاح النووي كراجع
ضد اي تهديد على روسيا واراضيها
لهجه حاده لمسؤولين الروس موسكو ترد
بالتهديد والتحذير على الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا
تهديدات لا يتردد مطلقوها في التلويح
بالخيار الاخضر
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين منذ بدايه
الحرب وضع قوه الرضع النووي في حاله تاهب
هدد مؤخرا برد نووي على بريطانيا في حال
زودت اوكرانيا بذخائر اليورانيم المنظم
وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويكو اعتبرها
مقدمه لصدام نووي محتمل تلويح بالسلاح
النووي لم يتوقف نائب رئيس المجلس الامن
القومي الروسي ديمتري
هدد بحرب نوويه اذا اعتقل رئيسه بوتين كما
لوح
باستهداف مبنى المحكمه الجنائيه في لاهاي
بضربه صاروخيه الرجل حدد ما قد يدفع روسيا
الى الردع النووي
اذا تحدثنا عن بعض الاشياء الجاده
المرتبطه بمحاوله استعاده شبه جزيره القرم
وما الى ذلك فقد تحدث عن هذا وكتبت عنه
فيما سبق من الواضح تماما ان هذه اسباب
لاستخدام جميع وسائل الدفاع بما في ذلك
عقيده الردع النووي
تهديدات من اجل التهديد ربما لكن كل
سيناريوهات التصعيد مطروحه ولعل اللجوء
الى سيناريوهات الرعب مرهونه بحسابات
الربح والخساره لدى بوتين
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
حمله اكتتاب جود الاسكان الخيري في
السعوديه نحو 430 مليون ريال خلال يومين
حياكم الله من جديد تجاوزت مساهمات وحمله
اكتتاب جود للاسكان الخيري في السعوديه
عفوا
430 مليون ريال وهو ما يشكل نحوه
43% من هدف الحمله والتي تهدف الى جمع
مليار ريال من خلال الاكتتاب في 100 مليون
ريال طيله شهر رمضان للاسهام في اسكان
3000 وخمسمائه اسره شديده الحاجه للمسكن
تواصلوا المنافذ السعوديه استقبال
المعتمرين من كافه انحاء العالم لاداء
مناسك العمره وزياره الحرمين خلال شهر
رمضان من الخدمات الكبيره التي تقدمها
الجهات المعنيه في كافه منافذ البريه
والجويه والبحريه وسجل توافد المعتمرين
ارتفاعا ملحوظا خلال شهر رمضان حيث شهد
مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده توافد
اكثر من 250 الف معتمر من الخارج خلال
الاسبوع الماضي
تنفذ هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي داخل
الحرم المكي خطتها التشغيليه من الخدمات
الطبيه الاسعافيه للحالات الطارئه
للمعتمرين والزوار والمصلين وتقدم الهيئه
خدمات طبيه طارئه خاصه باجهزه الصدمات
القلبيه والانعاش القلبي الرئوي
والتركيبها داخل الحرم وقد باشرت الهيئه
يوم امس اكثر من 36 حاله لمعتمر اصيبوا
باعيا وارهاق اثناء فتره نهار رمضان
من مكه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نصفين
هاني مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض من الحرم المكي الشريف
أني صفيان كل عام وانت بخير رمضان كريم
اولا نريد بدايه الحديث معلومات اكثر عن
ما تقوم به هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي
مرصدته انت ايضا خلال وجودك في مكه
المكرمه
نعم اهلا بك نايف واهلا بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه قبل ان نتحدث عن الهيئه والخطه
التشغيليه التي تنفذها هنا داخل الحرم او
المسجد الحرام في مكه المكرمه سوف
رصدنا هذه الصور الان بعد انتهاء صلاه
العصر داخل المسجد الحرام وكيف هي الحركه
تسير وفق الخطه التشغيليه التي عدتها
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين وتحديدا في المسجد
الحرام وكذلك امن العمره والحج الذين
يقومون بمراقبه سير المعتبرين هناك عدد من
الرجال الامن وايضا بعض ممن يقومون بارشاد
المعتمرين وكذلك ايضا هناك قطاعات وحكوميه
وخاصه تشاركنا في في المسجد الحرام من اجل
مسانده ومساعده المعتمرين اذا ايضا نعود
الان الى الموضوع الاساسي وجهود الهيئه
الهيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي والخطه
التشغيليه التي تنفذها هذه واحده من عربات
الجولف وهي التي تستخدم في نقل المعتمرين
او ممن يحتاجون الى الاسعاف اي يتنقلان
بكل يسر وسهوله هناك مسارات خاصه لهم كما
هو هناك الحال لمسارات مخصصه للمعتمرين
وكذلك المركبات الكهربائيه وكذلك العاديه
التي يستخدمها كبار السن وكذلك ذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه عموما الاستاذ يوسف
السمكري وهو مدير مكتب الهيئه هنا في
العصر المقدسه مرحبا بك استاذ يوسف وبينما
كاميرا العربيه ترصد هذه السياره
والاستعدادات دعنا نتحدث عن الخطه
التشغيليه وعن الحالات التي باشرتها هنا
تحديدا في المسجد الحرام طيب بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم استكمال الجهود التي تقوم
بها حكومتنا الرشيده في خدمه المعتمرين
لهذا الموسم تظاهرت هيئتان الاحمر حقيقه
مع باقي الجهود المعنيه ولخدمه الحاج
والمعتمر بوضع الخطط للاستعداد لهذا
الموسم عمره 1444
حقيقه الهيئه الاحمر رفعت جاهزتها في جميع
مراكز العاصمه المقدسه ابتداء من المنافذ
من المطار الخطوط السريعه المؤديه للعاصمه
المقدسه
تم تركيز على المنطقه المركزيه مساكن
المعتمرين تم تغطيه 18 نقطه في المنطقه
المركزيه الى بعض الاثنين واربعين نقطه في
الحرم المكي الشريف
استاذ يوسف دعني نتعرف على هذه
الاستعدادات وتجهيزات يعني زميلي نايف كان
يتحدث عن هناك اجهزه لصدمات القلبيه او
اجهزه خاصه بالقلب تم تدشينها مؤخرا
واطلاقها في خلال رمضان هذا العام نعم
صحيح تم تدشين المشروع
الجهاز
في الحرم المكي الشريف وتوفير 15 جهاز في
مناطق الحرم الاطاف اضافه الى المسعه
ومداخل الحرم المكي الشريف او حقيقه هدف
هذا الجهاز هو الاستجابه السريعه للحالات
توقف القلب والتنفس هو هذا الجهاز لا هذه
الاجهزه الخاصه بالفرقه الاسعافيه المباشر
للحالات وهي تستخدم من قبل الاخصائيين
وفنيين الطوارئ العاملين في الخدمه
الاسعافيه لكن الاجهزه التي تتحدث عنها
الان وهي تستخدم الخبره المواطنين اي شخص
على درايه كامله الاسعافات الاوليه
بامكانك طبعا او بالرسوم نعم صحيح خدمه
مجانيه
عدد الحالات التي باشرتها وهو ابرز هذه
الحالات ماذا كانت حتى الان تمباشره
نعم صحيح نعم صحيح 93 حاله منها منقوله
132 حاله نفس الموقع 93 لماذا نقلت كانت
رحلات عباره عن ايش نسبه 70% حالات كلها
حالات مرضيه حالات مستقره تم نقل المشاط
الصحيه للقرب الحرم المكي الشريف شكرا لك
استاذ يوسف اذا يوسف سمكري وهو مدير مكتب
هيئه الهلال الاحمر والسعودي هنا في
العاصمه المقدسه تحدث عن التقنيات
الموجوده الاداء الهيئه وكذلك عن الخطه
التشغيليه وبينما ايضا كنا نرصد الجهود
الهيئه هنا ايضا نرصد جهود الامن داخل
الحرم
المكي في المسجد الحرام وكيفيه عمليه
توجيه المعتمرين الى الطرق لكن اخ نايف
يعني هناك يعني
امر مزعج بالنسبه
المؤسسات العمره الذين حتى الان هم
لهم يعني لم يصلوا او لم يوصلوا المعلومه
الجيده والارشاديه الى المعتمرين خاصه
القادمين من الخارج حيث ان بعض المعتمين
القديمين من الخارج يسلكون مسارات غير
المسارات التي حددتها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
في المسجد الحرام والخطه التشغيليه وهذا
هذا الامر يقع عاتقنا على مؤسسات العمره
التي تتكفل بوصول المعتمرين الى المسارات
والمداخل المخصصه فمثلا هنا في باب الملك
عبد العزيز يواجه او تواجه بعض الايام او
بعض الفترات ازدحاما شديدا بسبب سلك بعض
المعتمرين وكذلك ممن يرغبون اداء الصلاه
الى نفس المداخل بخلاف المداخل والمسارات
الاخرى الاخرى التي حددتها رئاسه الشؤون
الحرام او شؤون الحرمين في المسجد الحرام
في مكه المكرمه اشكرك جزيل الشكر انت
وظيفك الكريم من مكه المكرمه من الحرم
المكي مراسل العربيه
تقوم رئاسه شؤون الحرمين بعمليات تنظيف
وتعقيم وتعطير لسجاد المسجد الحرام على
مدار الساعه وغسل 1500 سجاد اسبوعيا داخل
مغسله السجاده التابعه للرئاسه وذلك
للمحافظه على نظافته والتاكد من سلمته
ولضمان ايضا سلامه قصدي الحرم المكي
التفاصيل برفقه الزميل سلطان السلمي
[موسيقى]
35 الف سجاده خضراء تغطي مصليات وساحات
الحرم المكي بطول اجمالي يلامس مئاتكم
كالقى عنايه خاصه من قبل رئاسه الشؤون
الحرمين المختصه باعمال الصيانه والنظافه
والتعقيم باجود انواع المواد الصديقه
للبيئه والاجهزه الحديثه
[موسيقى]
تجري عمليات تنظيف يوميه للسجاد عبر خمس
مراحل داخل مغسله ضخمه تابعه لاداره
التطهير والفرش بمكه المكرمه على ايدي
مختصين
عن الطريقه خمسه مراحل المرحله الاولى هي
مرحله ازاله الغبار والنمس والاتربه اليا
المرحله الثانيه يكون غسل السجاد عن طريق
الشامبو والمعقم
بازاله الشامبو عن طريق الماء الصافي في
المرحله الثالثه يتم تجفيف السجاد عن طريق
عصره داخل انبوب في المرحله الرابعه يتم
نشر السجاد تحت اشعه الشمس والهواء النقي
حتى يتم التاكد من تجفيفه بعد ذلك المرحله
الاخيره هي المرحله الخامسه هي كنسل
السجاد وتعطيره بالمعطر الورد تبلغ الطاقه
الانتاجيه اليوميه لغسيل السجاد
240 مترا في الساعه الواحده وتعمل على
مدار الساعه لتزويد المسجد الحرام بشكل
يومي بالسجاد بعدها تشغيل الحرم المكي
بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه هذا العام من
مكه المكرمه سلطان السلمي العربيه
يشكل شهر رمضان تحديا للبعض للحفاظ على
الوزن وذلك لما تحتوي السفره الرمضانيه من
تنوع كبير بالاطعمه خصوصا مع تناول الكثير
من الاطعمه خلال فتره قصيره ما يسبب قله
النشاط ورغم هذا يتخذ البعض من رمضان فرصه
للتغلب على السمنه وتبعاتها كالتقمه
واضطرابات الجهاز الهضمي والتي تؤثر على
صحه الجسد ونشاطه ايضا
من جده تنضم الينا اختصاصيه التغذيه رويدا
ادريس دكتور رويدا مساء الخير حياك الله
معي من الرياض كل عام وانت بخير رمضان
كريم
اهلا وسهلا فيك خلينا نسال اولا لاي مدى
الصيام شهر رمضان فرصه لانقاص الوزن فرصه
لاكمال من بدا اي حميه غذائيه كانت على
مدار السنه وكانت ايضا حتى قبل شهر رمضان
ولا هذا الامر صعب يا دكتوره بسبب تنوع
الموائد الكبير واحتوائها على كثير من
الاغذيه الصحيه وغير الصحيه
[ضحك]
ما نبغى نقول اكثر اكثر الناس لكن مجموعه
من الناس على الاقل يعني طول هذه الفتره
اللي هم مفطرين فيها فهما جالسين جالسين
يعني ياكلوا كل ساعتين كل ثلاث ساعات
فبالتالي المحصله نهائيا انه نهايه رمضان
يصير في زياده في الوزن ويكون هذا الشهر
يعني وفرصه لزياده الوزن مش لانقاص الوزن
مثل ما قلتي صحيح هو المفروض انه ينقص
الوزن لكن زي ما قلت كل ساعتين ثلاثه
هياكلوا كمان ايش الاختيارات اللي
بياكلوها احنا ممكن انه تكون خياراتنا
اشياء صحيه ومفيده وتساعدنا لليوم الثاني
يعني انه نكمل صيامنا بصحه وعافيه لكن اذا
كانت الاختيارات اللي احنا حضرتك عمال
تقول عنها هي من الحلويات والمقليات
المحمر والمشمر زي ما يقولوا طبعا اكيد
حيزيد الوزن لكن احنا بنتكلم على الشيء
اللي يفترض انه ناتج عن الوعي الصحي اللي
صار في مجتمعنا الحمد لله دكتور بمجرد ما
يدخل شهر رمضان الكثير من الناس يتجه الى
البحث عن افضل رجيم في رمضان افضل حميه في
رمضان
واكيد الناس حتتجه الى الى الى الى محركات
البحث ويبدا يبحث عن افضل رجيم او كيف
انقص الوزن في رمضان وتطلع الاعلانات
الكثيره اخسر 30 كيلو في رمضان 20 كيلو
واتبع هذه الحميه الغذائيه ويعطيك جدول
منتظم واشيل المفروض انت تاكل وايش
المفروض ما تاكل هل يجب اتباع هذه النظم
الغذائيه ولا هذه فقط لمجرد تسويق وخلينا
نقول بالعمي يعني ضحك على الناس
هي التسويقيه بحته وده على كده انه
بيخرجوا من رمضان او بيخرجوا نتيجه اتباع
الاشياء الخاطئه او الحميات الخاطئه
بيخرجوا بزياده في الوزن وانا دائما اقول
لو نظرنا الى المنحنى حق السمنه خلال
الاعوام السابقه للان حنلاقيه بارتفاع
وليس بانخفاض فلو فعلا في هذه الاشياء
اللي ذكرتها انها تنزل وزن 30 كيلو وعشرين
كيلو وعشره كيلو في الشهر فكلها اشياء ما
هي صحيحه والنزول الوزن السريع اكيد حاله
مرضيه غير صحيه
فالنزول الطبيعي يكون في الشهر اربعه كيلو
على الكثير سته كيلو يعني هذا بالاكثر
خليني اختصاصيه دكتور دكتوره واخيرا يعني
ما هو افضل رجيم يتناسب مع شهر رمضان
اللي هي صيام المتقطع او الوجبه الواحده
هذا بيكون افضل انواع الحميات لانه
بيساعدك الوقت انه انت اساسا صيام فيساعدك
انك تاخذ وجبه واحده تكون متكامله وباقي
الوقت لغايه وقت السحور حيكون عندك
الزبادي والخضروات السلطات الخيار الاشياء
هذه والسوائل طبعا شيء اساسي ولكن نبعد عن
السوائل الغنيه بالسكريات اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من جده اختصاصيه التغذيه دكتور
رويدا ادريس شكرا جزيلا لك
العادات الرمضانيه في الاحساء متنوعه
وتعكس التاريخ العريق الذي تتميز به
المنطقه العم ابو مبارك احد المزارعين
الذين لا يزالون محافظين على العادات
والتقاليد الرمضانيه الاصيله الزميل عبد
الرحمن العصيمي التقى به واعد لنا تقريرا
ضمن سلسله تقارير رمضانيه جديده
[موسيقى]
في الاحساء الفلكلور الرمضاني متنوع ما
بين التجمع داخل برك السباحه في المزارع
وحضور الديوانيات والامسيات مساء حتى وقت
السحور الاول في رمضان الصباح بدري بدري
طال عمرك هايدي طبيعي ما في الا اذا احتد
الحر اذا جاء رمضان في حر
يريحون الصباح شوي يريحون اخر النهار شوف
العالم متنقعين في البرك وفي
الاعيان هذه الموجوده في الاحساء كل شيء
يشبه النخيل تاريخها اجوائها واهلها ما
طول العمر اني حتى دمه وصلت الدمام صدق لي
عشر سنوات ما وصلت الدمام مال العلم عندي
اختي واخوي مو على انها قطعه رحم لا والله
هم يجونا كل اسبوع على فكره عشان الوالد
وعشان امي العم صلاح المهيني يحن كثيرا
الى عادات شهر رمضان المبارك قديما
انقطع اي والله بطفيله هذا
كل شيء موجود اول لازم نربط
تقريبا قبل قبل
لا تخلو منها شوارع الاحساء بسطات الكبده
التي باتت عاده رمضانيه الى جانب الكثير
من الاكلات الشعبيه العريس طبعا
يتجزا من المائده الرمضانيه في الحساء
شيء اساسي وكل يوم كل يوم
سوى شوربه في الليل تريد كوسا قرع خضره
مشكلة من جمع كله على حسب كل شيء كل
الفوائد موجوده هنا
كل الفوائد موجوده هنا
ولازم يشبع بالماء لازم يشبع بالمول
[موسيقى]
فعلا ولا صوت لا صحيح
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من الاحساء العربيه
كان صوت حمار من جهه وصوته
وقت تعليقه
الله يسامحك يا عبد الرحمن الرابع مستمره
وفيها بعد قليل
الداخليه سعوديه اكثر من 12 الف مخالف
لانظمه الاقامه والعمل خلال اسبوع
حياكم الله من جديد انضم للمنتخب السعودي
للسيدات لكره القدم رسميا الى قائمه فيفا
بعد قرابه عام من خوضه اول مباراه رسميه
منذ تاسيس المنتخب واكدت المشرفه العامه
على كره القدم النسائيه لمياء بهيان
مضاعفه الجهود خلال المرحله المقبله
ليتقدم المنتخب السعودي منتخبات اسيا
للسيدات
اعلنت وزاره الداخليه السعوديه عن ضبط
اكثر من
16,500 مخالف لانظمه الاقامه والعمل وامن
الحدود خلال اسبوع معظم هؤلاء المتورطين
من مخالفين نظام الاقامه وذلك ايضا باكثر
من 9000 شخص الداخليه السعوديه اشارت ايضا
الى ترحيل اكثر من 12 الف مخالف واحاله
البقيه الاستكمال اجراءات السفر
في السعوديه انتهت هيئه التراث التابعه
لوزاره الثقافه من ترميم قلعه الامام تركي
بن عبد الله في مركز الحلوه بمحافظه حوطه
بني تميم حيث جاءت هذه الخطوه لاهميه
القلعه تاريخيا وكونها موقعا تراثيا يحمل
اهميه عاليه كما تضم القلعه مسجدا يعود
عمره الى مئات السنين بالاضافه الى عشرات
المنازل القديمه التي تم ترميمها بالكامل
ومعنى منحطه بني تميم مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
يعني انت في منطقه عزيزه وخليني اسال منذ
يومين وانت فيها عبد الرحمن ما الذي رصدته
في هذه
المنطقه منذ ان وصلت وتزامنا ايضا حتى مع
شهر رمضان
اهلا نايف طبعا الله يسامحك انت بعد رمضان
كريم علينا
ههه لا حجيب طريه بعد شوي مش حخليك انا
كويس انه باقي وقت على الفطور قليل يعني
ان شاء الله ما راح اجوعك كثير لكن نحن
يعني نقف الان امام صحيح هذا الرياض ما
يحتاج نحن نقف الان امام قلعه الامام تركي
بن عبد الله هذا القائد الذي اسس الدوله
السعوديه الثانيه يعود تاسيس هذه القلعه
نايف بحسب المصادر التاريخيه الى القرن
الثاني عشر الهجري سادع زميلي نصر المصور
ياخذكم جوله في هذا المكان الرائع والبديع
نايف اجابتنا على سؤالك يوم امس كنا عند
احد العائلات في حوطه بني تميم ضمن سلسله
التقارير التي سترافقكم خلال شهر رمضان
مائده الافطار في الحوطه رائعه جدا
ومختلفه ومدهشه القرصان والجريش والسمبوسه
والقيمات وايضا المرقوق ويعني تفاصيل
جميله نشاهد هذه القلعه الرائعه التي كانت
تضم منازل عديده تم ترميمه وايضا هناك
مرحله ثانيه نايف
لترميم المنازل المتبقيه لكن المرحله
الاولى انتهت بهذا الشكل الجميل والرائع
وهناك رضا كبير من اهالي مركز الحلوه في
محافظه حوطه بني تميم عن هذا الترميم
الرائع للغايه والحفاظ ايضا على مكتسبات
هذا التراث المميز طبعا نايف
اهل حوطه بني تميم لا يزالون يحافظون على
تقاليد وعادات شهر رمضان الاصيله بحكم
اولا مساحتها الجغرافيه الصغيره بالاضافه
الى انهم عائلات يعرفون بعضهم البعض وايضا
حوطه بني تميم اهلها لا يزالون يحافظون
على العادات والتقاليد القديمه المميزه
الافطار العائله كلها على مائه الافطار
ايضا افطار الصائم في المساجد ايضا
التكافل الاجتماعي نحن الان دخلنا الى
مسجد القلعه نايف هذا المسجد الذي يعود
عمره الى مئات السنين وصلى فيه الامام
تركي بن عبد الله مؤسس الدوله السعوديه
الثانيه طبعا الامام تركي اتى الى الحلوى
في حوطه بني تميم بعد ان احتل العثمانيون
وهاجموا الدرعيه اتى الى هنا لبضعه ايام
ثم
تحرك من هذه الايام لمحاوله استعاده نايف
الدرعيه
وتم ذلك بالفعل بعد ارتب اوراقه واعاد
تحالفاته عوده الى سؤالك نايف فيما يتعلق
بشهر رمضان المبارك هنا في حوطه بني تميم
الناس هنا نايف يعني يشتاقون الى رمضان
بشكل كبير جدا وايضا صلاه التراويح
المساجد هنا غاليه وما تكون مليئه
بالمصلين وايضا حريصين على التبرع خلال
شهر رمضان وايضا معالجه الاجواء بشكل كامل
نشاهد نايف هنا قبل الختام هذه الازقه
الرائعه والجميله بعد اعاده ترميمها ايضا
لاحظت نايف في العائلات هنا تاتي الى
القلعه في ساعات المساء المتاخره ايضا في
السحور والاستمتاع بالاجواء خاصه الطقس
هذه
وربما ان شاء الله اليوم او بكره يكون في
امطار ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يا رب
استمتع يا عبد الرحمن وانا عارف انك انت
اخذت مسافه طويله وانت تركض ورا المصور
الرائعه ايضا موجود مع كلي طلعت
القصير اشكر جزيل الشكر مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيبي من حوطه بني تميم
في السعوديه شاركت اسواق غذاء كبرى في
مبادره لتخفيض اسعار المنتجات والتي
اطلقها اتحاد الغرف السعوديه وذلك لمواجهه
مشكله ارتفاع اسعار الاغذيه التي تتزامى
سنويا مع دخول شهري رمضان
مبادره من التجار في السعوديه لتخفيض
اسعار السلع الغذائيه والاستهلاكيه
بمناسبه شهر رمضان
وتزايد الانفاق على شراء السلع الرمضانيه
20 شركه انضمت للمبادره عبر منافذ بيعها
الكبرى وتبيعتها مئات الاسواق الغذائيه
الصغيره والمتوسطه الحمد لله احنا سعيدين
اليوم صراحه في تجاوب المراكز التجاريه
لهذه الحمله والتخفيضات اللي اصبح نشوفها
على ارض الواقع وليس هي
يعني قول بالعكس ويتسابقون عليها يعني
اللي انا شفته اكثر من عشرين مركز تجاري
كبير على مستوى المملكه شارك في هذه
الحمله مبادره اتحاد الغرف السعوديه زادت
نسب التخفيضات على 141 منتجا استهدفتها
المبادره ملصقات ولوحات وعروض الاسعار على
جميع رفوف الاسواق وممراتها
هي المبادره هذه جيده لكن نحتاج الى
استمراريه هذه المبادره واستمراريه انخفاض
الاسعار والحد من التضخم الذي يعني طبعا
يعتبر عب على كاهن المواطن
المستهلك لهذه المواد علاقات رجال الاعمال
السعوديين من اعضاء اتحاد الغرف السعوديه
المتبني لهذه المبادره دعمت مشاركه الكثير
من قاده قطاع البيع في منافذ بيع التجزئه
بمختلف المناطق من الرياض نواف عزيز
العربيه
تنوعت قائمه الاعمال السعوديه في موسم
رمضان الحالي وتطغى الكوميديا عليها بسته
اعمال العلى ابرزها عوده مسلسل طاش ما طاش
طاش العوده بالاضافه الى ثلاثه اعمال
تنوعت بين التاريخي والدراما الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مو عيب اننا نطيح لاننا يا ولد نزل الشنطه
مرحبا اعمال سعوديه عديده تتنافس في
الموسم الرمضاني الحالي معظم هذه الاعمال
يدور في فلك الكوميديا بينما طبعا لا زالت
الدراما الجاده غائبه قليلا حيث يوجد ما
يقارب سته اعمال كوميديه في مواجهه ثلاث
اعمال دراميه انسانيه واجتماعيه طبعا هذه
الاعمال هي طاش ما طاش بجزء التاسع عشر
منه ولدنا الجزء الثاني سكه سفر بجزء
الثاني شباب البومب بودكاست واستديو ثلاثه
وعشرين في شهر رمضان طبعا اعتدنا ان نشاهد
المسلسلات والبرامج الكوميديه بكثره طبعا
المشاهد هو مستسلم من هذا الموضوع يعني
صاروا المنتج او صارت صار المسؤولين عن
الحركه الفنيه في السعوديه يعتمدون ان
الكوميديه تكون بشكل طاغي في شهر رمضان
والتصق هذا الشيء لسنين طويله مع العلم
انه عندنا الكوادر وعندنا الفنانين وعندنا
المنتجين وعندنا حتى يعني الافكار اللي من
الممكن تكون يعني بشكل كبير تغطي الدراما
عندنا في رمضان
كما ربيتكم وعلمتكم الادب
ورغم انه عدد الاعمال الكوميديه في تراجع
كبير بمصر الا انه في السعوديه لا زالت
الصداره للكوميديا وبحسب الاحصاءات يعد
رمضان والموسم الاكثر جذبا للانتاجات
الكوميديه بينما يغلب الطابع الدرامي
الاجتماعي الجاد على الاعمال المحليه طوال
العام وخاصه على المنصات حيث توقف
المنتجين هناك عن البحث عن الكوميديا
اليوم نحن نعيش فتره ذهبيه من خلال الدعم
من خلال تعدد القنوات عدد المنصه
اللهف والشغف
الجماهير لهذا الانتاج ايضا لا بد ان يكون
عندنا انتاج متنوع لجمهور رايه بالتاكيد
ما بين الكوميديا واشكال الدراما الاخرى
وخاصه فيما يخص الانتاجات السعوديه
[موسيقى]
تحصل اليوم ما راح تحصله
فيك زعلان
ما شاء الله عليك صدق
دايما احب ان ازرع البسمه امام الكاميرا
معروف انا ابي عفوي عفويه
ختاما الرابعه بابرز
اوكرانيا تقول ان جيشها حقق استقرارا حول
ضخمه وبريطانيا تكشف توقف الهجوم الروسي
على المدينه
مفوض سياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
يصفه خطه بكين لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه بغير
الكافيه
مطار الملك عبد العزيز بجده يسجل وصول نحو
ربع مليون معتمد لاداء العمره خلال شهر
رمضان
خلال اقل من عامين على تاسيسها المنتخب
السعودي للسيدات يدخل تصنيف الاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم
انقاص الوزن او الحفاظ عليه تحدي سنوي
يواجه غالب الاشخاص الصائمين خلال شهر
رمضان
شكرا لكم لكلمه لطفي المتابعه نهايه
الرابعه الى اللقاء